le Vatican annonce qu'il le donnera pas
suer à l'enquête déclenchée sur les
allégations d'agression sexuelle
qu'aurait commise le cardinal Mark
wellet entre 2008 et 2010 ces
allégations figurent dans une action
collective contre le diocèse de Québec
je suis un peu déçu mais je crois quand
même surpris compte tenu que c'est la
tradition de l'Église depuis tout le
temps Denis nier en 2021 le Vatican a
été informé dans les gation d'agressions
sexuelle concernant Marc wellay le père
Jacques servais qui a déjà collaboré
avec le cardinal Ouellet avait été
mandaté par le Souverain Pontife il
s'est entretenu avec la victime à léguée
maintenant que son enquête préliminaire
est terminée et après d'autres
consultations pertinentes le pape
François a déclaré qu'il n'y avait pas
d'éléments suffisant pour ouvrir une
enquête canonique pour agression
sexuelle par le cardinal Ouellet une
déception pour la partie plaignante et
pour d'autres victimes mais c'est
certain qu'on va demander une copie du
rapport
mais là on est capable d'y répondre
mais peut-être qu'entre temps on va
avoir l'impression ce sont des disciples
de Jésus c'est des gens qui sont
supposés en tant que le bon sens mais
non c'est pas ça qui arrive ça marche
pas alors donc qu'est-ce qui nous reste
à ce moment pour obtenir justice mais ça
nous oblige à aller devant les tribunaux
puis pour cette expert la décision du
Vatican pourrait s'expliquer par des
motifs plus complexes comme la
difficulté de juger de ses allégations
depuis l'étranger le Vatican veut
laisser les processus judiciaires
québécois et canadiens fonctionnaient le
Vatican fait confiance
à notre système de droit notre système
de justice il pense que l'essentiel
pourrait reprendre l'enquête si de
nouveaux éléments lui parviennent
cependant l'impact des allégations se
fait déjà sentir selon lui
prochain pour l'élection d'un nouveau
pape je pense que la candidature où elle
est maintenant brûlée le quel que soit
le jugement les cardinaux ne prendront
aucune ce sujet là quant à ceux qui
estiment d'agression sexuelle de la part
de membres du clergé les avocats leur
conseillent de se tourner vers le
système de justice plutôt que vers les
instances religieuses ici Flavie
Sauvageau Radio-Canada Québec